[Music]
eat slowly chew your food thoroughly eat
with a fork these table manners don't
apply in the world of competitive eating
or sometimes call speedy the goal here
eat as much as you can in a short period
of time
ladies and gentlemen so it is and so it
shall be
[Applause]
if you think the bigger the man the more
he can eat then think again I have about
28 world record you know different kind
of food most terrible my record was 552
Louisiana Acme Oyster 'he's 65 hard boil
eggs in 6 minute 40 seconds 11 pound of
cheesecake 44 laps ten lobsters in ten
minute Sonya Thomas one of the top speed
leaders in the world weighs just 105
pounds her nickname is Black Widow
[Music]
so this eating competition is all mostly
about 99% it's very competitive and I'm
the female competitor and I want to beat
them I wanna kill them
I want to kill him eating you know Sonia
is a fierce competitor and I think she
really likes us to put men in their
place I think she gets a little bit of a
kick out of that as for instance she is
so small it looks as if she couldn't
finish a tin of cottage cheese and the
guys next to her usually were so large
it looked like they had their own
ecosystem and yet she could beat them
[Music]
sonia claims she can eat 18 pounds of
food in one sitting
how can a 105 pound woman eat almost 1/6
of her body weight over time the stomach
progressively becomes more and more
dilated that this is an acquired
adaptation that resulted from endless
training discipline and willpower
however she doesn't Black Widow often
beats men at least twice her size the
intense competition regularly draws
hundreds of spectators this attention on
gorging mass quantities of food worries
dietitians like Mariana lupus from a
health perspective it's important that
they are doing things like having the
cholesterol checked and and taking an
active stance in their health pains my
concern from a nutrition perspective is
that speed eating or competitive eating
kind of glamorizes the notion of
overconsumption of food glamorous or not
it's unlikely we'll be seeing Sonia in
the Olympics anytime soon I always
dreamed one day that we would be in the
Olympics and my hopes were dashed on
that the IOC president Jacques Rogge has
been you know dismissive at best and
refuses to return any of our phone calls
you know I've moved on
you